joining us now one of the great players
in NFL history and this is the first
time we're talking to him since he
became a hall-of-famer he is Hall of
Fame receiver Terrell Owens tio how are
you buddy I'm good man how are you good
how do you like the sound of that now
when you hear yourself introduced as
Hall of Famer Terrell Owens still
probably three years too late but I'll
take it however you can however I can
get it but other than that mean I mean I
think it was something that was long
overdue and you know now I mean I think
it's a situation where now I just kind
of you know I'm recognized for really
kind of my accomplishments and what I
did in the football field and and you're
right it was overdue we had the
conversation last year at the Super Bowl
about it and I'm glad to see you get in
in hindsight what bothers you more about
it having to wait or the things that
some of the voters felt compelled to say
to justify making you wait well just the
latter quarter that is just them really
trying to again question my character
and I think you know from just from the
first nomination alone as these are some
of the things that started to kind of
circulate and I'm like what are you guys
talking about like I'm not this type of
person I'm like just because you may
have heard something from a couple of
guys or whomever even in a locker room
or coaches that doesn't speak for the
majority of the locker room just because
you made somebody an individual or two
may dislike me so that was something
again like I said because for me post
football you know the media is so
powerful and at the end of thing I'm
trying to do things post football off
the field that again these businesses
they really adhere to they listen to and
so when you start talking about
somebody's care and you're trying to
align yourself with businesses and
brands and trying to establish stuff off
the field they take some of these things
into account and so again they don't
understand you know what they say how
powerful it is and how meaningful ideas
and so for me I know who I am as a
person and how it was a lock home and
just that kind of further you know you
know kind of pinpoint you know some of
the character issue that no no teammate
has ever come out and say that I was a
teammate or I was terrible in the locker
room yeah I'm not just her standing
saying that I was perfect by any means
but not to the degree to have kept me
out from from getting what I rightfully
deserved which was my my Hall of Fame
induction the first time around and you
chose not to attend the ceremony let me
tell you I support anybody who makes
that decision it's up to you it's a free
country you don't want to go you don't
have to go but will you go at some point
to see your bust oh yes I mean I've seen
it you know I'll help Blair Boswell
Buswell who who basically does you know
some of the the bust I mean I saw it
firsthand I was very in stability and
the reproduction of my beautiful face
there and that's in campus I mean I've
seen it I was in San Francisco November
1st for the Hall of Fame ceremony ring
ceremony there so again I don't
necessarily have to be there I go there
but at one time I did want to be there
and go there with us with my family and
my kids and and Dave Baker and those
guys since then and even before they
said I'm welcome there they're gonna
treat me like family like I like it like
I belong but again my my my thing
against them was just it wasn't in
alignment you know everything that they
said when I was there when I went on the
visit it just wanted an alignment with
you know kind of the vision and the core
values of the Hall of Fame and again
they put too much power in those voters
and the writers hands that ultimately
end up this into the Hall of Fame
everything should be in alignment those
guys should be on one Accord and I think
that was a disconnect hey there's an
issue that you and I are in alignment on
and I could see it on Twitter this week
the horrendous call at the end of the
RAM Saints game the NFL's reaction to it
or lack thereof what do you think the
NFL should do about what happened in
that game I mean I think it wasn't like
this again obviously they filed a false
suit you know when you go to court again
like said whoever's the judge is you
know looking at all the things you know
all the evidence and things put together
to make up this case then you have to go
to the room and I know I have gone on
the air with
earlier and I and I spoke too much to
them about it and what's in the rulebook
is in there for a reason it again this
is a probably once in a million kite
thing that that happens but there's
probably like three things that happen
on that one play again you got the
helmet the helmet no let alone just the
P I in itself then you have the that the
defensive back who never even look back
at the ball so again all of these things
that occurred on that one particular
plate impacted really the entire game
and advanced things that new honest
things to the Super Bowl and so again it
should be about fairness it's about the
integrity of the game now you have two
teams and again you look at this
particular play and everybody's all up
in arms is all what about the game you
know what about the flags not throughout
the course of the game yeah I mean they
talk about the face marriage penalty and
in early in the game or in the teeth
name those are those are great area
plays but when you have a place like
this that is black and white that's when
you have to address it and Roger Goodell
gets paid a lot of money I mean a lot of
money to do his job and I think this is
where the onus is on him to take
responsibility next step up to the plate
as the Commissioner again it's not going
to be in the most unpopular decision if
he goes to the rule book in other states
that you know he has the politics to the
game or from the extraordinary act or
the a fraction of truth and so again if
that happens then you have the new RL
think everything to the Super Bowl I
can't emphasize it enough Mike that the
rules are in the book for a reason but
again whoever made up these rules they
understood that there there is something
that pop there's a possibility that
something like this could happen and in
this in it and this in this case it
definitely warrants you know these rules
to be looked at and I I agree with you
completely on that and we'll see if they
make any fixes or changes going forward
you know when you think back on your
career and you played a long time you
accomplished a lot of things is there
one moment that stands out for you is
the proudest moment of your career
I'm the proudest moment ah I don't know
I think probably if I look back on it's
probably just you know I guess when I
played in Philly and you know the
efforts that I made you know to get back
to play in the Super Bowl understanding
that and you know I was risking my
career I end up having a sign a waiver
just to play the Super Bowl because of
the extent and the severity of my injury
that I had and you know I think again
there was such a misconception about Who
I am as a person but I think as I said
earlier there's not any players that
openly come out and say but I was a
terrible teammate I think that nobody's
a hundred percent liked in the locker
room I think that's you know you can ask
anybody you know any sports for that
matter so for me I think the proudest
moments just being really knowing that
you know if you put your mind to
something and for me I'm a god-fearing
man and I was raised in a church where
my mom my grandmother basically told me
is like no if you have faith you put
your faith in something nothing isn't
impossible and so for me to do what I
did and it kind of just you know really
be behind my teammates and my teammates
behind me and just be in that suit and
play in that Super Bowl in the played
the way that I did I think that the
efforts that I put forth and the
training staff at that time to help me
get on that football field and everybody
that that was involved I think that was
probably the proudest moment that I can
I can remember no call right now Antonio
Brown and the Steelers currently have
something going on I don't know how it's
gonna play out I don't know if Antonio
Brown wants to be in Pittsburgh I don't
know if they want him there but what
advice would you have for Antonio Brown
right now I mean I've talked with
Antonio Brown throughout the course sort
of year and I was kind of known some of
what has been going on he's leaned on me
for advice and somewhat of a mentor so
to speak and you know I think he's done
well let me just sometimes not really
saying what he really wants to say I
think just going out and just playing
and I think he's allowed his his play to
really be at the Forum
forefront of where he goes to next
because again regardless of all the
issues that are inside that locker home
or what-have-you
I think his best asset is just and I
think if you move in for
about where he wants to go it's his
production on the football field again
like I said he hasn't been healthy but
at the same time again there are things
that are gonna surface a lot of get
blown out of proportion
but I think you know with him and
management and the organization I think
if you notice some of the some of the
quotes coming out coming out of
Pittsburgh is that they don't think that
he's going to be there and I think they
have to do what's best for everybody all
parties involved and and try to try to
go their separate ways amicably if
that's possible or if it's not amicably
then just part ways because it's not
going on it's going to be a recipe for
disaster as you've seen with the lady
unveil situation and some of the things
that I've heard in the course of the
season so I think with him I think it's
a fresh start to go elsewhere and part
ways with the organization and some of
the things that you know he and being or
have been confronted with I think it's
best for him and his family to just go
on and do what's best for his family and
thank you like is it best for the Miz
part ways and I've gotten the impression
that he's ready to move on I get the
impression that you've come to the same
conclusion absolutely and I think it's
it's no secret now I think everybody's
kind of just airing you know putting
their cards on the table I think he
won't still evils to move on I think
that management knows that they want to
at least try to maybe salvage but at the
same time they want to get something in
return if they do in fact release him or
whatever the case may be so again they
don't want to just let it go and get
nothing in return
so I think there's a lot of creative
ways to possibly make that happen and
I'm sure if it bodes well for both
parties then everybody be happening in
the long run but I don't like you know
just speaking with him and what I've
seen you know from from afar I don't
like how Ben has kind of thrown him
under the bus and in some sudden
interest is and and just not spoken in a
in a more of a cohesive and again
chemistry type you and especially when
you have a quarterback of his stature in
a receiver of his stature and what
they've been able to accomplish over the
course
of the years that they played together I
think being owes him a lot more of
respect and he's given him by just
sending subtle messages you know through
certain things that he said he said you
know throughout the media I mean even
from the standpoint of him saying he
didn't know anything about a blow-up
when he was a part of the blow-up yeah I
mean how can you say that when you know
everybody in that locker and around
around the world know that there was
something that went on during that
course of the practice that means you go
on radio and say you don't know anything
about it
ato it sounds like that locker room
could use a nice blast of Febreze which
is put to use what do you got going on
with Febreze this year well yeah that's
on our second year partnering with them
they're the official this is the third
year that they are the official sponsor
for for the Super Bowl so again I
couldn't be more excited just to be a
part of and just be a part of that the
creativity and you know we've got I had
just you know that this kid a little bit
and it turned out to be fun but
everybody knows across the country I
mean there's going to be a thousands and
millions of Super Bowl parties so you
can imagine you know people out of the
country
you know what's being cooked up for
Super Bowl with all those different
different dishes and here in the states
you have obviously your main staple of
pizza and nachos and and God knows what
else and then you know with all these
foods counts you know the bathroom is
going to be probably the most huge
facility of everything so you got to
keep your Febreze in stock and again
like I said I couldn't be more proud to
be able to promote this odor-eliminating
MVP that's best that's going to be that
the Febreze is the MVP of the Super Bowl
this year that's for sure hey buddy it's
great Tigers oh one more real quick do
you get the sense where Antonio wants to
play I'm from from what I've heard I
mean he wants to I've talked to him on a
couple of occasions Mike and and I said
I'm not here to air anybody's you know
you know messages or anything
conversations but he's asked me about
how the Bay Area was on several
occasions he wants to play there but I
didn't get a sense that he really wanted
to play there I just thought he was a
kind of exploring his options again you
know he asked me how I could be area or
not on occasion so you know I said he
can't beat the weather out here and for
somebody with his ability and a guy like
Jimmy Garoppolo you know at the
quarterback position hey you never know
what can happen you know you see how you
know how they play with and without
Jimmy you think of bringing an offensive
weapon like that you know to the team
that team can go a long way can shake up
the NFC West and then possible hey you
throw me in the mix you know somewhere
down the road really enjoyed talking to
you we looking forward to talking again
down the road and congratulations again
on finally getting into the Hall of Fame
even though it's a few years too late
thanks pal it's a pre-shave thank you
Mike Tirico and thanks for watching make
sure to hit subscribe for the latest
news and highlights from NBC Sports